la séance est reprise et l'ordre du jour
appelle la question orale numéro 291 de
Monsieur jean-Patrick Courtois monsieur
le ministre chargé des transports de la
mer et de la pêche vous avez la parole
monsieur le Président merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre je me
permettais d'appeler votre attention sur
la distinction budgétaire qui doit être
appliquée par une autorité organisatrice
de transport public entre l'organisation
des transports publics stricto-sensus et
l'organisation des transports scolaires
lors d'examen du projet de loi de
finance pour 2011 et pour 2012 je vais
proposer par le biais d'un amendement de
préciser dans l'article
l233-68 du Code Général des
Collectivités Territoriales relatifs au
versement transport que ce dernier ne
puisse être affecté au financement des
transports scolaires au sens de
l'article l213-11 du code de l'éducation
en décembre 2010 monsieur Richert alors
ministre des collectivités territoriales
avaient admis qu'une clarification était
nécessaire pour éviter tout ambiguïté
quand au versement transport
cette précision de droit a d'ailleurs
bien été rappelée dans la circulaire
ncot du 28 mars 2011 relative à l'usage
relatif des crédits du versement
transport or ce rappel c'est à vérin
suffisant et l'ambiguïté demeurée et ce
bien que le 5 décembre 2011 lors de
l'examen du PLF pour 2012 Madame Valérie
Pécresse et Madame Nicole brick alors
respectivement ministre du Budget et
rapporteur général de la commission des
finances est à nouveau confirmé que le
versement transport ne peut être affecté
au financement des transports scolaires
en effet force de constater que
certaines dérives perdurent quant à
l'affectation des recettes du versement
transport pour les organismes en charge
du transport conduisant parfois la
suppression du service transport de
voyageurs dans certains secteurs
géographiques pour assurer le
financement du transport scolaire par
ailleurs une telle politique conduit à
laisser les usagers du transport public
en ne parlantant pas du fait de la
démission des financements d'instaurer
une politique tarifaire incitative
notamment au profit des catégories
sociales les plus défavorisées
que cette situation risque de s'aggraver
avec les changements de rythme scolaire
prévus pour la rentrée prochaine chez le
site donc aux gens de rappeler dans les
médias dédiés par le biais d'une
nouvelle circulaire par exemple les
modalités du versement transport ou de
le spécifier très clairement dans
l'instruction générale adressée au
préfet avant la préparation des budgets
locaux un insérant dans les lignes
budgétaires versement transport une
séparation entre transport urbain et
transport scolaire cette distinction
permettrait non seulement préfet lors du
contrôle de l'égalité mais aussi aux
Chambres régionales des contes de
visualiser clairement l'affectation du
versement transport je manque donc
monsieur le ministre de bien vouloir me
faire part de sentiments sur cette
suggestion merci la parole est à
Monsieur Frédéric Cuvillier mini chargée
des transports de la mer et de la Pêche
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames
laissez natris monsieur sénateur ce
sénateur les lois de décentralisation
transférées au département au début des
années 80 la responsabilité de
l'organisation du fonctionnement du
transport scolaire c'est un transfert
qui était justifié par les
caractéristiques même du transport
scolaire Vous en avez d'ailleurs fait
état dans votre question qui était
essentiellement un transport intérieur
basse c'est-à-dire principalement assuré
en pratique en dehors des périmètres de
transport
urbain sur lequel peut être levé le
versement transport
la loi a toutefois prévu le 15 août à la
date de la décentralisation les
transports scolaires seraient assurés à
l'intérieur des périmètres de transport
urbain dans ces cas l'autorité
organisatrice des transports urbains
demeurent compétente et sauf à ce qui
est une présentation séparée des budgets
les transports scolaires font
l'objet d'un financement qui ne fait pas
de distinction avec les autres services
de transport public c'est votre demande
de clarification c'est que et vous y
faisiez référence là aussi cette
question a été à plusieurs reprises
soulevées et a fait l'objet de
nombreuses discussions au sein même de
votre assemblée d'un certain nombre de
précisions ont été apportées y compris
par mes prédécesseurs alors faut-il pour
autant chercher nécessairement à séparer
c'est votre demande pour ne pas dire
opposer le transport scolaire et les
autres transports publics
transports publics sont accessibles ils
sont accessibles au scolaires et tout
comme les transports scolaires peuvent
être et doivent être d'ailleurs
accessibles aux autres voyageurs alors
pour éclairer notre débat il est
important de rappeler que le transport
public qu'il soit scolaire ou non dépend
finalement
des subventions qui
que verse les collectivités locales et
ce même après prélèvement du versement
transport par conséquent la
clarification de l'affectation du
versement transport m'aurait modifierait
assez peu l'origine même du financement
du transport et cela reviendrait à la
situation de vases communicante purement
comptable entre deux activités celles
financées par le versement transport ou
celle par des subventions d'équilibre
alors
vous demandez vous appelez de vos vœux
une circulaire dont le fondement légal
puisque vous faites référence au
contrôle de l'égalité avec la circulaire
ne peut être qu'interprétative ceci
étant aujourd'hui je pense que les
autorités organisatrices des transports
urbains ont aussi leur responsabilités
peut-être de faire en sorte que les
budgets puissent être présentés de façon
distincte séparée elles peuvent le faire
pas une obligation et dans la mesure où
ça permettrait peut-être une
clarification entre ce qui permet par le
versement transport de financer le
transport urbain et ce qui est
finalement financé par subventions par
impôts
permettrait peut-être de clarifier les
choses moi j'aurais tendance à me
tourner vers la sagesse des
collectivités peut-être même leur
souhait de clarification lorsque cela
est nécessaire sachant que
les OP et les autorités organisatrices
de transport ont tout intérêt à
optimiser et faire en sorte que
l'efficacité du transport vous situiez
un certain nombre de situations où le
transport
urbain était
plus organisé au détriment en tout cas
le transport scolaire se faisait au
détriment du transport urbain ce qui est
une situation paradoxale vous en
conviendrez et inversement que Paris
situations peut se produire dans un
équilibre qui laisserait pas
suffisamment avéré entre les deux autres
il en est de la responsabilité des
collectivités des autorités
organisatrices de transport également
des opérateurs de faire en sorte qu'il y
ait une réponse au besoin de services
publics de mission de service public du
transport public et là encore si le
besoin de clarification et de séparation
se verrait être nécessaire il appartient
aussi aux collectivités de pouvoir même
spontanément organisé une information à
la fois des mais aussi de la population
dans une présentation comptable adaptée
merci monsieur le ministre monsieur le
Président courtois oui merci Monsieur
ministre en fait il faut être clair avec
les entreprises qui payent le versement
transport et qui souhaitent elles que
leur va se mettre en transport aille
pour le transport des usagers avec
notamment une politique tarifaire
intéressante pour les particuliers qui
sont en situation sociale difficile les
chômeurs les personnes handicapées et
autres et aujourd'hui comme les masses
sont regroupées dans le budget on peut
plus faire la différence et les
entreprises ont l'impression qu'elles
payent à la place des collectivités le
transport scolaire ce qui n'est pas fait
d'ailleurs par rapport à la loi sur le
versement transport qui est dit
clairement que le versement transport
doit servir au paiement des transports
des usagers merci de votre réponse mais
je crois qu'il faudra qu'effectivement
un jour on puisse clarifier les choses
et je manquerai pas de signaler aux
autorisations aux autorités
organisatrices de transport l'intérêt
qu'ils aient à présenter un budget en
toute transparence de leur libre chef
certes en toute transparence pour
permettre un contrôle efficace des
contributeurs